[Music]
hey Rach Deadpool vs Batman fine but I
got places to be alright so we're gonna
set this to the Batcave because I
started this whole argument I want to go
to that kid
well I'm done with that because back
here's also my Deadpool guess we'll see
the costume room right but Batman
knowing that Deadpool is arriving is
going to be waiting over the rafters
looking down scowling what awesome good
Deadpool I know it's going to be a huge
fan of Batman like I'm pretty excited
well that's a good thing because you're
going to see the Bratz brute do that yes
are you sure yeah right into the
computer screen okay well that doesn't
matter because Deadpool's going to have
pineapple surprise the fights on let's
find out what surprise super named man
the other play mole vs. Capcom whoa bye
I could be usable approved cake honey
oh no I'm Batman whatever man one of us
has to be an adult
we got to have rules okay fine let's use
the ultimate versions of the characters
you can't have like the best Batman ever
I put the movie versions of the
characters well then I get Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool that's fine I get bats like
that's fine but that means we got to
start over
oh man I'm so considering the fact that
that life is a resource-based Batman as
we've seen in Batman V Superman we're
going to go ahead and assume that he had
lowered as Deadpool into an abandoned
warehouse where they can settle their
differences I don't know how things work
over in Batman land but here we call
that kidnap lured kidnapped it really
doesn't matter that means there's a
couple of slow fellas - the ground that
he swings in and starts punching and
kicking Dental - hopefully you know
subdued him okay well if we're talking
about Ryan world's dead for which we are
then let's just kind of consider the
fact that he was doing flips and spins
and all that kind of stuff in the air so
he's like flip instead of way out of the
smoke and then he's not being you know
blinded by throw for anything the fight
goes right back to it was before so I
mean we're talking about Deadpool with
this prodigious martial
and combat skill is clearly going to
overtake babban okay well then during
all the flips and spins Batman threw a
battery that had glue tablets on it
blocking Deadpool in place I'm gonna go
ahead to say maybe his hand in his lair
glued to the ground that okay
okay like what man can can do that
alright call me a little dangerous here
but in the moments event we'll have you
just going to shave off that little
layer of skin that has the glue attached
to it and free himself again I mean sure
give me until when will you kill what
he'll get in pain things will be okay
alright well while you're shaving off
layers of skin which is apparently a
thing that Deadpool can do I'm now
giving here we've got a katana that
doesn't matter because in that time
Batman it through you looks a net over
Deadpool holding him down Eve it's
better
okay well Deadpool customer match you're
not making this hard on Deadpool man
you're making this pretty easy I thought
Batman was the master detective so far
you show no real detective Oh detective
you want to know what detective work
does well Batman has also learned you
know that Deadpool could regenerate
because he's attempted he did the
research required for that and that's
what he pulls out a gun Batman doesn't
use guns I know there's a precedent for
this so originally in the 1940s Batman
didn't use guns to achieve his goals you
know it was an older comic book though
so we could say that that was ignored
later when they decided to be more
family-friendly but this has been used
in more recent years you seen Arkham
Knight he had a Batmobile that had riot
suppression bullets on it and those
bullets were used to shoot at people but
they were like beanbags and stuff like
that but even in more recent stuff
because we're talking about bats like
that like uses the Batman gun to shoot
the pair of demons and then when he was
fighting the sons he went ahead and
grabbed their guns shooting other people
and that's something she made home
that's how I remember it
so what I'm telling you is Batman can
use guns as long as their special ammo
or somebody else has them haha so you're
telling me
you're going to use firearms yeah on an
immortal firearm expert yeah you're so
cute
did you just slap me yeah weird you know
what it is weird almost as weird as you
believe in the devil would stand a
chance when Batman loaded up special
explosive round as we've seen in the
past when he realized that solomon
grundy would heal
he knows that death was going to heal
using that detective work Rob so he
launches an explosive round a Deadpool
okay well then that's what we'll just
take that explosive round like a chance
because Deadpool is amazing he's going
to walk upon Batman
there goes Batman Scott okay well Batman
immediately easily grabbed enough to get
up into the rafters where he was
responding with multiple side of the
battery we've got one sets like we got
ones that night he's probably got one
that makes julienne fries it doesn't
matter he's for a gathering
nothing like while dodging these places
you know he's heavy stuff on Batman
being such a good attentive
how could a detective forget that the
building had been literally wired to
blow
so what a Deadpool do he blows it up the
eager to take a whole building down
around Batman's ground battery what
because Deadpool can live well since
Batman is once again a detective and a
very resourceful Batman he was prepared
for this potential and evitable
explosion says he's done research on
Deadpool that knows that you know
Deadpool just wind despites with jokes
and explosives so said he sees it coming
he runs up the back to find his ultimate
weapon the bat family no no oh did you
count on call in the whole Batman as you
can is one of his printable powers how
about family a power okay
Batman has three powers that are not
normal one is money
two is the utility belt with the answer
to everything and three is the bat
family sure we haven't seen it was that
like yet but it has been heavily implied
alright whatever
you can have a bad thing exactly he has
the Grayson Barbara Gordon Jason Todd
Kendrick
if you're at Damian Wayne nobody cares
my David I did to call in Deadpool's
sidekick
that's all doesn't have a sidekick some
people call them sidekick some people
call a partner i Carlin cable cable
isn't that like the really old mutant
that comes back in the future and
assassins guns you're just bringing more
guns to a fight that I now have the
entire Batman theme ahaha
but see cable is it a mega level telecom
what does that mean it means that people
can use cystal epopee to stock the
brains and remember the bad family from
being able to allow their bodies to move
so now you're all basically just lost in
place you can go anywhere that's the
luck Tyrion will in a while because now
Deadpool mister put party hat it's not
in Phoenix region what a party happening
how's it going to win your fight a party
hat no man this it's celebrating with
the inclusion you wonder why because the
occasion your fellow that family and
that means dead they're all having their
heads chopped off right now they're
hoping those eggs chopped off what do
you mean right now like yeah we're
cutting like this was killing the horse
also know that this heads gonna go off
and again you lose put them in one never
lose what to say man Batman always wind
up until he doesn't whatever I got the
next one so what is all this even for
what why are we here
no we're having a party a party I love
party I can't wait to go to your party
what's going on Rob core really hope you
guys enjoyed the video that video myself
put together the first in a mini series
that we have coming out putting two
color book characters that we love and
you guys love against one another if you
guys enjoyed this and you want to see
more make sure you guys like and
subscribe and if you want to see the
ending where Batman wins and Vinny lives
up to every forum post ever from every
Batman fan ever then go over to college
story that's nothing to celebrate
going down ghosty college story and go
check out the video over there thanks
for watching guys please